perfect tech stacks are rare in an
imperfect world but i think the flutter
firebase stack is about as close as you
can get
today's tutorial is a setup guide for
developers building a serious mobile app
flutter and firebase you'll learn the
basic setup steps for ios and android
how to set up a local development
environment using the new firebase
emulator suite then we'll implement
analytics to understand our users
crashlytics and performance to improve
the quality of our app
and finally we'll look at app
distribution to test our builds before
they get in the hands of actual users on
the app stores
by the end of this video you should have
a solid foundation for building pretty
much anything you can imagine with the
flutter fire stack well if anyone wants
to develop an app with me i'm down
we'll be starting this video with the
basic setup but if you want to jump
ahead to the fun stuff
check out the time stamps in the video
description as you can see here in vs
code i have a freshly generated flutter
app if you're not sure how to get to
this point
check out the official install
instructions for flutter from there
we'll open up the pub spec yaml file and
go to the dependencies section
firebase maintains a variety of
different plugins for flutter
the only one that's actually required is
firebase core everything else you can
just pick and choose as needed
most apps will use firestore as well as
firebase auth
and i'm also including the google
sign-in plugin to support that sign in
method
from there we have analytics and we'll
also throw in performance and
crashlytics
i'll explain what all these do in more
detail throughout the video in this demo
you'll notice i'm leaving the version
numbers empty
however it would be a good idea to peg
these dependencies to a specific version
just so they don't break when you update
things you'll find the latest version
for each plugin and the firebase docs
that takes care of our initial flutter
setup now we need a firebase project
if you're brand new to firebase i'd
recommend checking out my firebase
basics video
oh and by the way if things are going
too fast in this video make sure to
follow along with the full write-up on
fireship io that breaks everything down
step by step
but at this point we just need a project
in the cloud that we can link to our
front-end app now it's time to configure
this app for android from the settings
tab in the firebase console we'll add a
new android app
we need to decide on a bundle id which
is like a reverse domain name
so in my case it would be io dot
fireship followed by the app name
the bundle id needs to be unique and it
will be shared across ios and android
so make sure to choose it carefully
below that you'll notice it gives us the
option for an sha1 certificate
it's technically optional however you
will need one if you're using phone
sign-in or
google sign-in on android back in vs
code let's open up a terminal session
and then we'll cd into the android
directory there's a script in there that
we can run
to generate the sha-1 certificate for us
that'll generate a bunch of output
and then at the bottom you can find the
sha-1 certificate for the debug android
test variant
so go ahead and copy that and then paste
it into the firebase console
go ahead and create the app and then it
will ask you to download the google
services json file
download and save it into the android
app directory
this file contains your firebase project
information so it can be identified by
the android app from there you can just
click through all the other steps and
then you should see your app created in
the firebase console
let's head back to vs code and find the
android build gradle file
in the dependencies object you'll want
to add a class path for the google
dependency
of version 4.3.3 then what's kind of
confusing here is you have a second
build gradle file in the app directory
go into that file and then add this line
to apply the google services plugin
directly below the plugin for the
android application
then moving down a few lines you'll see
a default config object
you'll want to update the application id
to use the bundle id that you created in
the firebase console
and then one last thing that we'll do
here that's optional but might be an
issue that you run into in the future is
enable multi-dex
firebase provides a lot of functionality
which means a lot of classes and methods
in your code
multidex simply allows you to support a
large number of references
so let's go ahead and enable it and then
we'll add it as a dependency down here
at the bottom as well
and now we should be good to go with
android flutter run should build your
app without errors at this point
now we're ready to move on to the ios
setup which is a bit easier
especially if you're familiar with xcode
in the flutter project in the ios
directory you'll find an xcode workspace
file
now go ahead and open up the project in
xcode keep in mind that you do need to
have a mac device in order to do this
however there are ways to build flutter
apps for ios without having a mac
however that's beyond the scope of this
video
in the general settings you'll want to
go in and enter your bundle identifier
then under signing and certificates
you'll want to go in there and make sure
that you have a valid signing
certificate for your apple developer
account
if you don't have one or not sure what
that is you can follow the official
documentation on the apple developer
site
the next thing we'll do is go back to
the firebase console and this time add a
new ios app
this time we just need to add a bundle
id and then it will give us an
info-plist file to download
go ahead and open that file in finder
and then drag it over to the runner
runner directory in the xcode project at
this point you should be able to click
the play button in xcode or run flutter
run from the command line
and the app should build successfully
now at this point your app is good to go
for both ios and android with the basic
setup
but if you're building a serious app
here that you plan on launching to the
app stores
there's probably a few other firebase
features that you want to take advantage
of
the first one we'll look at is firebase
analytics which is just a proxy for
google analytics
basic usage of google analytics simply
collects metadata about your
users like where they're located what
type of device they're using
what screens they view and so on now
this data by itself is very interesting
to look at and provides a ton of insight
about your users
but the really awesome thing about
firebase is that you can easily take
action based on this data here's an
example if you've ever used the reddit
app you might notice that you start
getting notifications
based on a subreddit that you're
interested in you could do the same
thing in your own app with firebase by
collecting analytics data about the
topics users are interested in
and then send notifications to that
specific audience you can even custom
tailor the app experience at runtime
using remote config
and a bunch of other advanced stuff
beyond that as well the first thing
you'll want to do is make sure you have
analytics enabled on the firebase
console if you didn't do it when you set
up the initial project
in our flutter code we'll then import
the firebase analytics package
and then declare a global variable for
analytics then we can define that
variable in our main function
as an instance of firebase analytics it
will automatically start collecting some
basic information about your users but
you can also add custom events to it as
well
you'll notice on analytics that there's
a bunch of built-in methods and i
recommend using these built-in methods
if they fit your needs
however in many cases you may just have
your very own custom event
in which case you can call analytics log
event with the name of the event
and then some optional metadata that you
want to collect beyond that
in this example here i have this logic
set up in a method so that every time we
click this button here in the ui
it will log an analytics event now in
this very simple app we have one screen
but your app will likely have multiple
screens with flutter's navigator
in my full flutter course on fireship we
have multiple screens
and in order to easily track analytics
for each screen
we have a navigation observer set up
that automatically tracks every screen
view as you can see here in the source
code on github
and that's just another really easy
thing you'll want to do that adds a lot
of value to your code base
now let's move on to the next firebase
superpower performance
basically it's a tool that allows you to
measure the duration of time
for different things that happen in your
app by default it will measure the app's
startup time
but you can also set up your own custom
traces for any logic in your code
now the awesome thing about this is that
it collects and aggregates all this data
over time
so if you have a certain trace that's
running and then suddenly that trace
becomes much longer
it's going to create an issue for you
automatically and that means you can
hopefully address it before it turns
into bad reviews in the app stores
in addition it's segmented by app
version country and so on
allowing you to understand how this data
trends over time including firebase
performance in your code we'll set up
the automatic traces
and then we can set up our own custom
trace in this method here first we
create a new instance of a trace by
calling firebase performance instance
new trace and give it a unique name when
we're ready to start it we call the
start method
and in this case we'll await a future
for five seconds
and then we'll stop the trace when you
click the button it runs that
performance trace in the background and
then you'll find data about that trace
in the firebase console
so performance is one thing but if your
app is crashing or throwing errors
that's an even bigger problem a few
years ago firebase acquired fabric from
twitter
and one of the key features in fabric
was crashlytics it's a service that
allows you to detect errors that happen
in your application in production
and that's really important because if a
user downloads your app and it
immediately throws an error
well what they're going to do is leave a
bad review in the app store before we
set up crashlytics i first want to warn
you that the setup i'm showing you here
might be slightly different than what
you see in the official documentation
but i can tell you that as of today the
implementation i'm showing you here
works
to set it up on android we'll first want
to go to the android directory to the
build gradle file
under dependencies you'll add the
firebase crashlytics gradle class path
next we'll go to the app level build
gradle file and first apply the plugin
of firebase crashlytics and then we'll
go down to our dependencies and add the
implementation for firebase crashlytics
at this point
run the flutter clean command to wipe
out any cached data and then restart the
application
in our source code we'll implement
crashlytics and then we'll reference the
crashlytics instance
and set enable devmode to true now
devmode is really only intended to
verify that crashlytics reporting is
working properly
so after you start getting reports in
the dashboard you can set that to false
for most of your development
now what we want to happen at this point
is for crashlytics to catch every error
that's thrown by the flutter framework
and we can handle that by listening to
the flutter error on
error event and that's basically all we
need to do to get comprehensive error
reporting across our entire app
for example if we have a method that
throws a flutter error we should see
that error reported in firebase after we
click this button
if we go up to the firebase dashboard
you may not see any error reports at
first
because by default it filters everything
by fatal errors
but in the case of a flutter app
everything is considered a non-fatal
error when you click on an event it will
tell you how many users are affected by
that event and how often it's happening
and on what devices in addition it will
tell you the line of code that's
affected and provide a stack trace for
the error so you can immediately
pinpoint where this is happening
i can tell you from experience that this
data is extremely valuable
so many bad reviews on the app stores
are related to uncaught errors and
crashes
if you do client work you'll have a lot
less anxiety knowing that you can catch
things like this before they become a
major issue
and speaking of catching things early
firebase has yet another awesome feature
called app distribution
this feature allows you to easily
distribute and test both an ios and
android app on real devices
without having to jump through all the
hoops on google play or apple test
flight
if you've ever released to the app store
before then you know it takes 24 hours
or more to get your app approved and
there's a bunch of forms you have to
fill out it's just a really annoying
process
allow me to demonstrate with android
first we'll run a production build for
our app by running flutter build apk
that'll take a minute and then you
should see the app.apk file in the build
directory
from there you can go to the firebase
console under app distribution
and upload your apk there once uploaded
you can either create an invite link or
you can set up testers and groups
in this case i'll just add hello at
fireship io as a tester
then i can go back to the releases tab
and distribute this app to the tester
the tester should immediately get an
email with instructions about how to run
the app
and now something that would normally
take the better part of a day now just
takes a few seconds
at this point we have a solid foundation
for building a serious app
but there's one more bonus topic that i
want to show you and that's setting up
the firebase emulator suite
to have a mock database in your local
environment so you don't have to create
real data in the cloud when developing
in the past most firebase developers
would create multiple projects
one for development and one for
production however managing multiple
firebase projects can be pretty tedious
and that's especially true for flutter
apps
simply because you're targeting multiple
platforms here's how we can use the
emulator suite in our local project
first install the firebase command line
tools i'm using node.js to do that
next i'm running firebase init to
connect our project to the cloud the
tool i'm interested in here is emulators
there are multiple
emulators for things like cloud
functions and pub sub but for now we'll
just emulate the database
so we'll choose firestore in this case
you can select the default options for
everything else that gives us access to
the firebase
emulator's colon start command if we
follow the link to localhost 4000
you can see we have the firestore
emulator running and then it has a ui
that's similar to what you would see on
the firebase console the key difference
is that the data in this database is
stored on your local device
so you can safely create database
records without incurring billing or
polluting your production project
now we just need to tell our flutter
source code to use this local data
instead of the real firestore database
and the way we do that is by modifying
the settings on the firestore plugin
you can only do that after the widgets
have been initialized so you want to put
this code somewhere like a nit state
when you know that the widget tree has
been initialized we'll want the host to
point to our local instance of firestore
if using an android emulator you'll want
it to point to this ip address
10.0.2.2 but anywhere else you should be
able to just use localhost 8080. from
there you can set the options for ssl
and persistence to false now when we run
the app you'll notice that the data it
uses
is from the local firestore instance and
not the actual cloud that we pay for
i'm going to go ahead and wrap things up
there if this video helped you please
like and subscribe and consider becoming
a pro member at fireship io to get
access to even more flutter firebase
content
thanks for watching and i will see you
in the next one